Whitney starts off this hour from
Youngstown Ohio hi Whitney welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay I
have a question my husband and I have
been through your program from the very
bottom we've moved in with my parents we
paid off a debt we've bought saved up by
emergency fund saved up our 20% down
bought our house we are at that point
yes we worked it from the very bottom
it's incredible but now we are in a
position where we are extremely
comfortable my husband's a cop I work
part time and we are certainly
comfortable but we have these friends
and they are extremely wealthy and they
love us they take us to concerts they
take us to up to dinner they invite us
to these extravagant things that my
husband and I would never ever get some
Styrian because of everything because of
how much money it would cost but they do
it often and my husband and I feel like
we're almost like we feel like we're
kind of you freeloading but it's just
like we don't have anything to get back
with the places they take us for dinner
and seats that they take us to concerts
in like we could never even afford to
pay for or we could never even like say
hey can we pay for the tickets and you
guys say for dinner like and we just
don't know what to do like if you if you
like had a couple like that in younger
couples debate would you expect
something back or and you know how old
are these people we they are in there
like very early 50s like they're just
the one major anything weird about the
deal other than I thank you very
uncomfortable
no they are wonderful they are they
mention my husband they actually when we
were in the middle of our debt they a
bird like in the mo of our debt snowball
and everything we moved in with my
parents they gave us they gave us a
house on one of their properties to live
and write free to help us get through it
I mean I mean they helped us get through
your program not by giving us any money
but they just did things that made it a
lot easier for us but they just
opportunity that most people don't get
so how often do you eat out with them oh
my gosh my husband probably goes out
they
good Tuesday he goes out probably once a
week with the guy and then like the
other night they took us to a concert
took us there important Steakhouse and I
mean we could never go to Martin
Steakhouse and even afford the paper
floor people and I just feel like in my
husband and I like only should I move
money all the seedings and try to like
go like offer to pay or I mean is this
is something they love joint it is
something they love doing the only
downside of it is is that it's reached
the point that you're uncomfortable what
that's that's the only problem with it
and and I don't want you to I mean if
they wanted to do something nice for you
occasionally that's fine the the pattern
is what's starting to be a little weird
I mean they've obviously done very well
and they're they're wanting to pour into
year-olds lives to a let you experience
some things and be to do some mentoring
with your husband so that's all that all
sounds very healthy and very fine and
you know Sharon and I are in of that
situation Whitney I mean there's times
that we have you know we do have built
Lord has blessed us with tremendous
wealth and so it's not unusual for one
of our friends to not be able to do some
of the things and we just go hey you
know jump in and go with us you know and
because we just like hanging out with
them and we don't mind paying for it
it's not that big a deal but we don't
want them to feel uncomfortable and
usually what we've found is is if
there's too much of a pattern where
we're picking up stuff we're picking up
stuff we're picking up stuff then
eventually somebody becomes
uncomfortable and so you know we've got
up occasionally we just have to stop and
play cards right I know our not stop and
you know do something a little bit less
expensive and you know let's do the
cheaper version of this I know you guys
normally do this you've got a lot of
wealth but you know that you're pushing
our uncomfortable button but
occasionally you know if you want to go
to a concert or something once a year or
they were taking you on a trip or
something once a year that that's not
too bad but you just need your receiving
then and and again they like hanging out
with you but this sounds like you're
kind of also feeling relationally
smothered a little bit well not I don't
know about that well the way you just
kept saying like it's all the time it's
all the time it's all the time
but they like this
and I feel like we should like it's not
that it's not all the time I guess it is
all the time but it's not like
smothering it's just like and I don't
know I don't feel comfortable with them
like always paying like I wish I could
pay my own way I wish I could but you
can't you can't play on their level
you're not at their level and you're not
50 you're not in your 50s either right
by the time you're there you might be
because you're working our stuff you
probably will be able to you're not are
playing you know what you want to do is
be a gracious receiver because that's
it's their ministry to let you all do
some things and spend some time with you
and you enjoy their company obviously
yeah yeah that's fine
and but when it reaches the point that
it's often enough that it crisscrosses
your all's comfort button you just need
to have you need to have a talk whether
we go guys I've got up I've got to slow
this down a little bit it's freaking me
out a little bit because I feel
inadequate and I want to be able to
receive but I don't want to be receiving
so much that it makes me feel weird and
I'm starting to feel weird so we need to
back this off just a little bit I'm
guessing they'll understand that ok cool
can if they won't understand that there
is weirdness that you're not seeing
right ok
the thing that kick there's nothing
offices they invited us to go to out to
Vegas this fall and now the way we're
going to Vegas is a way that we number
evarin Lanier's get experience and I
just feel like now when we go out there
like how you know well I mean the same
thing happen to us when we were when we
were broke and starting to rebuild after
we'd lost everything I was 29 years old
and I had a friend of mine that was in
our church that was a about 15 years
older than I said owned a big company
and he took us on a trip and paid
everything to Vail Colorado and I you
know I think I probably taken a whole
lot of other people there since then or
out on a ski trip since then and paid
for it kind of to pay him back you know
because it really did but but we didn't
do it all the time I mean it happened
like once you know now and so it was a
wonderful blessing though so again you
just got to think about
the frequency is more concern to me than
the item you know a trips not the end of
the world but if it's going on and all
the time and you're starting to feel
uncomfortable with that part of the
pattern then I would back it off a
little bit yeah thanks for the call
it's a neat situation to be in
appreciate you joining us open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you know speaking of millionaires
and wealthy people you're able to do
anything you want to do we've been doing
a millionaire theme our here on the air
or we have millionaires call in and a
millionaire someone whose assets - their
liabilities equals a million dollars
what you own minus what you owe equals
at least a million dollars is not your
income if you are a millionaire we're
getting ready to load up another one of
these millionaire theme hours I want you
to email me at Dave on air at Dave
Ramsey com put your phone number in the
email so Kelly can get in touch with you
Dave on air one-word no-spaces no dashes
Dave on air at Dave Ramsey dot-com and
put your phone number in there and tell
a little bit of your story your net
worth and Kelly I'll get in touch with
you we'll make you part of this upcoming
millionaire theme hour